how are you good to see you it's good to
see you too
i'm good i'm good i get to
work from home and yeah i'm good how are
you
i'm doing the same actually we're in the
same situation look at that yeah
so what does it say to you that you know
the mcu wants to lead
their new chapter with your story well i
think
um i
i mean it was it was kind of
intimidating
you know to to be especially since black
widow
wasn't able to be released to be the
first that fans
have um have seen and
um i feel very lucky because this is a
really unique
and fresh and new way of telling
um our superhero story and uh
it was a blast because of how how
different
it was yeah i think of everything
announced this is actually the most
intriguing one because
people can't look given the marketing
materials people don't really know what
to make of it
so how did deep how did they bring the
idea to you like what
were your first thoughts well they
brought it to me
in more detail than i'll bring to you
but it is one
vision um in suburbia trying to not be
found
out and trying to live as normally as
possible
and it just happens to be a sitcom which
you know to me allows for a twilight
zoney
opportunity because it is sitcom smashed
with the marvel cinematic universe and
so i think
playing with that tension was um what
was really exciting
for us did you spend a lot of time
watching like
bewitched and brady bunch and i dream of
genie and all that stuff kind of like to
get into the mode because we have in
this
in our house we have fans of all those
things plus the mcu so this is a crazy
like mashup for us well that's a perfect
house
for our show um yes we did we did a boot
camp as an ensemble we got all the cats
together and um our director matt
jackman
the creator jack schaefer and we we went
through
um decade for decade what we were going
to be
doing a callback to and yes so there was
a lot of
dick van dyke show and bewitched and
brady bunch and
and then eventually modern family and
malcolm in the middle
um when things get a little bit more
chaotic and cynical
the fan theories around this show have
been swirling i'm
kind of like extra hard like there's
always fan theories but this is like
because people are trying to make sense
of what's going on and yeah
um you know i i happen to know like the
history of
wanda and vision when it comes to the
idea of
the kids the twins do you think that
they want to envision would like twins
to follow in their footsteps in their
super heroic footsteps
oh i i think that they would welcome
whoever they become because they're
gonna love their children
unconditionally regardless and they
would
they would allow them to just become who
they were you know destined to be
uh finally before we go what is the
nerdiest thing
you can say that you own and why do you
love it
the nerdiest thing um
i'm not much of a collector of things i
am
the only the only thing that comes to
mind that i don't find very nerdy
but maybe it is is um i love
collecting um vintage film posters
and my first one i've had since i was 16
17 and it was a nanny hall poster
and um i don't find it nerdy though but
i that's me being a you know
film fan that's actually super cool okay
well thank you so much
for your time great talking with you
thanks